candace owens is the host of candace on
the daily wire and we're grateful to
have her now ken it's great to see you
so
they are intentionally
making things worse because tearing down
what we have is a prerequisite to
building utopia i think that is the
answer to what we're seeing
that's exactly correct and this is a
especially sensitive topic for me today
because i spent the earlier part of the
day speaking to a north korean defector
and i was actually horrified hearing her
speak about what she lived through while
she was in north korea and understanding
that you know what they're really trying
to do right here in america is build
exactly that model where the state
controls and owns and operates
everything you will have nothing and you
will be happy because you have served
some higher purpose some higher
government some higher idea what you're
talking about these ideologues some
higher idea green new energy you did it
for your planet you need to have nothing
you need to shut down these pipelines
you'll not be able to afford to fill up
gas but look at you you should be proud
because now this is a part of the green
new plan and by the way if you want
anything you gotta worship government
this is the whole reason why when you
talk about what is the thing that
connects these attack of the education
system why are they dumbing down kids
why are they being so horrible about
families why do they want parents why do
they want children turning to government
and not to their parents for answers
well one thing that ties this all is
that they don't want there to be
anything but the state in your
individual lives in fact one of the
things that this north korean effector
told me was that there was no concept of
love right she said we don't we don't
have words like stress we don't have
words like social justice
in korean so there's no concept of this
in the state because they don't want you
to even think about that because you're
supposed to know that this is how things
are supposed to be every movie that
they're allowed to watch in north korea
and this really terrified me the only
concept of anybody dying is for the
state the highest honor is for the state
we're seeing right now people thought
this was a radical concept years ago
this is a republican talking point it's
not we are seeing america being
radically transformed into a communist
country that is what is happening right
now people need to wake up to the sucker
i cannot say it enough because it's
happening quickly how they done it they
needed an existential crisis well kobit
19 is their never ending existential
crisis this is why we have to take
everything that you own this is why we
have to shut down your businesses this
is why you can't earn a living while we
take trillions for ourselves because
we're here to help no we're not we're
here to take over every aspect of your
lives and welcome you to a socialist
reverie
it just feels like the cost of this is
getting really high you can feel
underneath i mean there are a lot of
signs without being too specific but you
can kind of feel the society going
sideways
underneath i mean you could see actual
unrest that's the last thing anybody
wants do you think they're aware that
they could be
putting too much pressure on the
population
i think they're aware but i don't think
they're scared you know i think this is
something that's been going on going on
for a very long time it's gonna begin
with joseph biden we know that you know
hillary clinton would have been a person
that helped to catalyze this had she
have gotten had she had become our
president but she didn't get that and
they felt like trump actually stopped
their plans you know they started this
process very slowly and nobody really it
was a way to it i certainly was and i
thought okay maybe maybe we are just
trying to do some socially good things
maybe they are just trying to help
everybody out but then suddenly when
trump was in office it became very
apparent that something else was
happening in this country you know this
this obsessive focus this obsession and
focus on racism on white supremacy um
making children say look
anything that happens in this in this
country is the fault of racism not the
obvious fault of what's standing in your
face which is that it is the fault of
government every hardship that we're
facing right now in this country is
because of the government we're not
building back anything better right now
tucker and americans need to wake up to
that fact
kenneth owens thanks so much appreciate
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else